Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
So, Diane wants to get out of my room.
Right?
Okay.
Nope, you're not allowed back in.
If I sound sad slash tired, I am both.
I had a really rough day today, which is why I'm streaming.
I'm streaming today, because even though it is my rest day, the one thing that I know that cheers me up the most is hanging out with my dragons, make me feel a lot better so um there's a lot of stuff that happened today but one of the things that happened recently was that um dad couldn't get his um uh dad couldn't get his uh refill on his kidney medication today because i was waiting for the refill too at my vet because like they're like we're gonna order the we're gonna order the medication for you and i waited like so yeah it has a couple of days now um and then like they're like we have to order it because i didn't want to do like an emergency order from the hospital uh because it costs more so i was like okay he can go about his medication for a couple of days because i ran out um and uh so i they for some reason the vet he's fine still i mean he's still a fucking brat he's fine i hope i i think so um but um anyway like,
uh, and then I was like, that's weird.
They said he'll, how he get his medication, like, you know, the, like, in like two to three days.
And I was like, it's more than two to three days.
So then, to women.
Black, yeah, thank you, material, awesome.
Thank you.
Um, and then, like, uh, today I got a call from my vet, and they were like, um, so we received the medication.
Like, we ordered your medication, but like, we don't have the prescription.
description to give you this medication so what's up with that and i was just like what because and then so that was like i had i left the voicemail i called them back and then i left the voicemail and because they're like we can't give you the medication so that we figured this out and the thing is the when i called them back they're like there's nobody there at the receptionist so please leave a voicemail but like the vet didn't close until two hours so i was just like what and then so I called them like four times I left a voicemail and I called them like four times around those two hours and never received like I never received a call back so I was just like okay what the fuck so after the vet closed I called the hospital I called a hospital it was like can I get emergency refill because at that point I was like I don't want to wait any longer so I was like um can I get an emergency can I go emergency refill because like for some reason you guys said you sent the medical records to
my vet and i've called you three to four times to send the medical records to my vet but they still haven't received it so i'm fucking confused they received the medical records for his like back surgery and they have the records of that but they don't have the records for his kidney shit so i was so fucking confused i was just like calling them i was just like hey so um so can you please like send them the medical records and they're like and then like I called they called me back like oh we did send them the medical records I was like are you sure like yeah we received the back stuff but what about the kidney stuff like I don't know why they still haven't received the kidney medical records so they're like oh we'll send it again and then they're like so about the emergency refill uh you missed the appointment um in August so we can't do an
what I don't remember that but I don't know I guess that happened but I was just like but I got an emergency refill last month I was just like what I got an emergency refill last month what do you mean they're fucking counting my August appointment date so they're like yeah so um I don't know fucking no I guess like the other receptionist I called like three times before it get an emergency refill like they didn't care but this one cared this one cared so they were like um um so i was just like oh so i need to get a recheck up to get his emergency refill and they're like yeah but internal medicine they're closed right they're like you know they're not there right now so you got but we'll leave a voicemail for you so you can get a recheck up uh for it the thing this is a hospital like it is an emergency vet hospital so it's not like it's like a vet vet it's like a 24-hour emergency vet hospital for he got his back surgery and we got diagnosed for his kidney troubles so um so i was just
like oh um when can i get the next appointment because he needs his kidney medication and they're like well um you could take him in through emergency
for an emergency checkup and maybe you can get your emergency medication by the way the emergency checkup is like 300 plus dollars so i was just like what the i was just like oh my god and like and they look at it via you know i don't remember what it's called um they look at it like because he doesn't i can't like i know i should get pen insurance but it's or he already got diagnosed for like for a thing so it's like a lot harder i'd like to get the insured like i know i should look into it but like um anyway anyway so um so they're so they're like yeah you can bring him in at any time because it is 24 hours for the emergency vet um and that doesn't include the refill too by the way because the emergency checkup is like 200 to 300 plus dollars yeah because insurance doesn't yeah do much after he got diagnosed for his kidney stuff um so so i was just like i was just like oh okay and they're like yeah you can bring him in whatever for emergency by the way i've been to emergency before
for emergency event and like i waited there for two like two plus hours depending on like and then the thing is so i'm waiting i'm gonna stream until it's later because at this time I know there's there's still going to be looking at like dogs so at other patients because like they're they do it via tears you know like the what's the medical tier like we're like they look at which one is the most severe like the most severe case and then it goes down and like you know dad uh that the tri-triag I don't know how to pronounce it so I'll go over there at a later time that's why I'm also streaming um because I like if I go there now I'm pretty sure it'll take a while for them to see dad because like at this time you know like there's gonna be a lot of patients um in emergency and like because dad is only like looking at his like checking like I guess like the I forgot like the um testing the kidney and stuff um so they don't see that as like super urgent too because he's getting a
re-checkup for it just to be like okay how like do we continue the medication but the thing is they literally told when they prescribed me the medication they're like yeah he's gotta be on it forever like so i'm like why do i need to re-check up if he's gonna be on that fucking medication for the rest of his goddamn life like i just i don't understand they're like yeah he's gotta do a recheckup before we can prescribe him new like pre-prescribe him the medication but i was like bro you said you said he's gonna be on this medication for the rest of his fucking life
like is it gonna be like magically gonna be better
like it's for the dosage yeah like the thing they're like oh if it gets worse and you give him more of the dosage i i would know that part but like the last when i was there like because this would be his second checkup because like he has that no he yeah yeah he has that like no his third checkup because he had like two other checkups and they're like yeah we keep the dose the same like nothing seems to be wrong we'll keep it the same um um so no the thing is it doesn't go less they said like oh this is like the dose the average dosage like like they we don't minimize that it's like if it gets worse he gets more dosage so like that's why i'm like really worried about because like it's been like a couple of days now since he skipped the medication so like i've got god i'm starting to get a little worried so well not a little because that's why i was like really like sad like because i was just like oh my god like i thought i could like i was just like oh my god i didn't want to pay for
the emergency room for and then like and now i'm like going through all of that yeah um um so so that's why i'm also streaming so i could pass the time to wait until it's a lot later so i could take i have to take him to emergency i have to take him to emergency uh to like uh to like uh get his uh prescription um he's like he if you look at him you'll be like oh he's bald but also he sees a very he seems like a very healthy dog he has too much energy and like he has a lot of fucking energy um it's just the fact that like uh he does have like kidney like um he does have like kidney issues where i don't remember what i don't remember what exactly he has they're just like we got he's got to be on his medication for the rest of his life and i was like okay okay um i don't know i think you guys might remember but like i've sort of like i've sort of like blocked that part out of my head and i've just like you know just been yeah oh yeah digesting protein yeah yeah it's like he has apparently
issues, uh, he's like peeing too much of his protein out.
Um, so that's what, um, that's what it's for, basically, is to make him make sure to keep the protein in his kidneys.
Um, uh, so yeah, so I'm gonna go take dad to the emergency later, later tonight, so he can uh, get his medication and, uh, God, we all love him, but holy fuck, man like i'm sorry he is um he is an example of why purebred dogs are slowly becoming a problem he he is so expensive like he is absolutely i would say a genetic mess and i say that with love with a lot of love but by god he is absolutely a example of royalty the issues the issue of being royalty you know when he was a puppy he seemed okay also oh my god thank you so much for the great thank you thank you uh alec alec thank you so much i hope you had a good stream today i'm trying to pass the time and try to keep my mind off things by playing some rivals at a decently appropriate time at a decent time versus versus my usual degenerate hours um whatever happens win or loss um um whatever i don't care i don't care I'm just here to be my,
like, be your usual E-O-M-M agent.
What time do you plan on going?
I plan on going maybe around midnight because usually that's when, I don't know, that's when, like, I don't know.
Maybe there's less emergencies going on at midnight.
I don't fucking know.
The last time I was there was like, it took me like two to three hours to be seen.
So I was just like, I was like, I'm not, I'm, I'm waiting.
I'm waiting.
Like, dad, you can, you're just going to get, you can get your, your kidney medication, like a little later because it's like, I, we're just going to be waiting there anyway.
If I, it's going to be, I know like at this time, there's going to be a lot of people there.
Do a face reveal?
I'll pay you.
Pay me first.
Prove it.
Pay me first, night.
Come on.
I'm waiting.
Yeah.
Where is it?
I'm waiting.
You think I'll show the goods without pay?
I need to pay dad's bedfills.
Anyway, anyway, but yeah, so other stuff also was like, made me sad.
But this was like the new, the recent thing, the recent thing that was like bumming, like I say, bumming me out.
But no, I was, I was raised.
I did have like a good cry before because I was like super frustrated.
Because, you know, I thought I was just getting his, I thought I was just, you know, getting his medication.
And then I had to jump through so many hoops.
And then I had to take him to emergency.
And I'm just like, oh my God.
Like, I just wanted a refill.
I had, like, the other times I called the hospital for an emergency refill.
They were like, sure, we'll get it sorted for you right away.
It's because I called out a decent time.
The other times I've done an emergency refill, it was midnight.
I should always call after midnight.
I had competent people at the receptionist.
Yeah
It's because I had competent people that were trying to make we got to follow the regulations So that because she hasn't had her checkup
She hasn't had a checkup we got to have her I think that's why I'm like you know what at midnight I'm gonna go back and ask if I could go get a refill on some medication and see if they give it to me.
Yeah, they give it a thousand bitties.
Thank you.
So maybe I could just pay for the medication and I don't have to, uh, I don't have to, I don't have to like fucking, um, um, pay for the emergency checkup.
Yeah.
I got, maybe the less competent receptionist will be.
I mean, like, that's really bad.
though like not like it's really bad that the incompetent uh uh receptionists are are there after midnight because of you know you would want your pets to be taken care of by like competent people and not like you know willy-nilly just handing out medication everywhere but we don't care about that now now i don't care about that i i i want my medication like
We don't care about that.
Yeah, I think it was a...
Oh, wait, I already read that.
But, but, do I cry and study?
You can cry, study, and watch the stream as well.
Hey, Tempo.
Are you excited for Saturday?
Come on.
Are you excited for the Nokia Hot and Seek tournament?
No, he's the organizer.
the thing yeah
that's that's um also like i know tomorrow is the guys i do know tomorrow is the street fighter tournament and i'm here playing marvel rivals i think i have two daredevil players i don't have an excuse i i don't have an excuse guys but i know
Okay, I'm actually really worried I'm going to lose to the iron and the rookie player as well because like I don't know I feel like I'm just such a fucking wild card.
I don't know.
I might do like really well in like it like Like I don't know it really depends on how Um on how like like um If my gamble is a success or not Yeah
Just remember what I learn.
I just need deep stress and Street Fighter makes me stressed out.
It really does.
I just want to chill.
Well, the thing is the other two players have not been playing at all.
Like, I, I, I was like, watch, you know, I, you know, I wanted, I studied their bots and like, one of them, like, such two are like Rookie and Iron or Rookie and Iron.
They haven't been playing.
that much i've been scouting it and then but sarah the one who plays aki she's not technically not a new player but like since it was like she had to fill in last like last two day notice um i guess like they were just like well she's like we don't want to give like an actual newbie newbie um like an actual newbie newbie a super hard time so i think i i don't think i'm gonna win against because she actually plays the game.
Like, I picked it back up, like, you know, this week.
Like, I don't know, guys.
Like, I legitimately don't think I can, like, I...
Like, if I do get, like, a round offer, it'd be, like, a fucking surprise to everyone.
Like, yeah, like, she's not new at the game, like, the others.
Like, the others are actually, like, picking up for the first time.
And like Aki is like a counter to me too like counter to Honda because like Honda can't fucking do shit with range Okay, we're so fucked I don't think our team's gonna win this Well, not the street fighter the rivals I don't know about my team.
I haven't been scouting like my own teammates You know like bro my own teammates just scout for themselves like I've been scouting for my like the the Ryu and the jury I'm like I think I if I like if I cheese it I can win it I can win it easily because my cheese is so fucking tilting to play against but I literally don't know if if I can beat the Aki like oh my god I can't see I also can't see Woo!
All right, that's fine on my lap.
I played, okay, guys, I played Street Fighter 4 like a year ago.
And then I never, and then I didn't touch the game after.
Literally after stage of slam, I understalled the game.
Because I was like, I need my hard drive space, you know?
I was like, I need my hard drive.
I was like, no, that took up a lot of my hard drive.
I don't know.
I'll be playing.
That's what I was like.
Oh.
Hey, guys.
Oh, my God.
Literally.
got no hills no hills right now what okay how are we losing i don't know i'm i'm just a little rat oh shin they got no hills what are we doing i'm just a rat because we did fucking bad daredevil after they said we they have two daredevil one tricks what the fuck was wrong with us for not banning daredevil we had the intel it's fine i don't even know we've made it puerto hello everyone what the what the fucking hill something what the fuck oh you guys are useless healers ggs what do you mean oh my god all i do is right like how how am i jump isn't even in vc so no it doesn't matter fuck it All I was doing was right-clicking.
How do you not get the right-click?
Just say it.
There's nothing I can't fix.
Bro, it's not drinking my fault.
Bro, they're doing extra time.
30 seconds before you attack.
We have to do Animal Crossing.
Yeah.
Why did we ban cloak?
Bro, if I played Luna or Invis, I get absolute fucked by the back, the backline.
There's like nothing I can do.
No, that's, it's like DPS players.
it's just your usual dps player rage like bro if i if i was not on rocket i'd be i'd be so like i'm still dead but like bro they're literally on they're on magic venom and daredevil why the fuck would i swap off rocket like
like why the fuck would i swap off this character
Like...
Oh my god, yeah, I'm fucking...
Like, this is the most I can get...
Oh.
I thought you guys were fucking bots.
Jesus Christ, worse than bots.
Okay.
I don't think we are the problem, buddy.
I...
Bro, there's no way I'm playing loot.
Oh my god, this guy, all he does.
Oh yeah, funny for the...
Okay, I'll tell you guys a story.
Okay, um...
Um...
I mean, sure.
Like, I think we have to at this point use this.
I...
Okay, funny story.
Um, but I was playing off stream.
And I had two, like, semi-pro players.
I say semi because like They're like I don't think they're in like Tier 1 they were in Tier 2 And they thought they Like they were semi throwing my Like not my game Our game Because they're like I mean not I don't know I don't want to say Avoid this whole BOD ass team I won't be like including legend Okay
That's crazy.
I feel like, I feel like, um, I feel like he's also part of the bad.
Like, no, no, he's right to initiate it because our team was actually terrible.
I feel like we should, but I gotta, I gotta see it.
Is he, that's weird.
Why would you ever link your Discord when you're that much, when you're that toxic?
I would say if you have that attitude, I don't want anyone knowing my Discord.
Even though it's obvious what my Discord is, but I don't want anyone, like, I don't want to link my Discord if I'm that much of a toxic person.
Yeah, keep that to yourself.
Yeah, at that point.
Keep that shit to yourself, buddy.
but okay funny story um okay i thought it was really funny so basically i'll queue up um yeah uh basically uh what happened was that i got in game with two really good players uh but they were on their alt accounts they were on their alt accounts and um they were just like bucking around not like not trying because they're you know they're on their own accounts they try that hard they just want to play other characters and stuff and they're not on their mains and then i was on stream mode but the moment my name was not streamer mode they were like also they were talking a lot in bc just around and stuff because we're like oh we need another support and they're i'm not gonna go support i'm gonna go ultra and like just like you know ultra luna or whatever and It was like,
obviously, like, that's not a great heal cop.
And, um, and so, like, and then the other guy, I don't remember the other guy was like, I'm not going to play tank.
I'm, this is my DPS account.
And they were just fucking around VC, you know, having fun.
And then the moment my name got off stream remote, they were like, oh, fuck, it's Doki Bird.
And then we're like, get into school.
God, I need to, he was like, telling this right, bro, get on squad VC.
No, don't use team VC.
Get on squad VC.
And I'll, I'm
sorry, Doki Bird, we're trying.
to try now like please don't report us we're gonna try and they're like bro chill I'm not I was like bro chill I'm off stream right now I'm just chilling and they're like oh thank God but they're like please we would try oh and then they're like they're like Doki you can avoid us we'll throw next game if you're on the enemy team
I was just like, oh my god, like we're sorry, we're so sorry.
That's crazy.
I know, I was just like, what?
Because they were so scared, because they thought, they thought they were on stream.
And I was like, bro, chill, I'm not streaming, man.
I'm not streaming, it's okay.
I thought it was so fucking funny.
Uh, but yeah, but I thought, yeah, I thought it was so fucking funny.
I was just like, whoa, what the fuck?
I'm just, bro, I'm the EOMM agent.
What the fuck are you guys doing?
I, I'm the one that's fucking around.
I was so surprised.
I was like, what the fuck are you guys worried about?
I'm the agent here.
all right
you're reporting too many people directly to the chest
yeah the two people i reported the two people i muted
that was funny though that was fucking funny i just love how they're like joki avoid us we'll throw it next game i wish i was streaming though that was fucking funny
i will have you know i will i will be i will be honest with you guys chat i i won't hide it i did avoid them
but i didn't get i didn't see them again but chat i unfortunately i didn't or fortunately I didn't see them again so but they okay no you have no you don't understand they were you know no you don't understand they were they were sort of throwing when they didn't realize I was on the team they were sort of throwing like because they're you know they're on their altar castle they didn't care because they're like whatever fuck they're just playing for fun not actually to win um um because they were going like Iron Man Ultron at first just to be like like you know just to have fun you know and then and in the moment my name came like got out of streamer mode they were on their main characters their main roles we still lost by the way we still lost so that's why that's why they're like I'm so sorry Tokyo I we we swear we We're trying so hard.
They were like hard.
They were hard calming and everything too the moment my name Like showed up on stream like out of streamer mode and we were losing they were like hard calming and they're like guys Come on.
We can win this like
No our team was absolutely terrible including me.
I was there
Bro, I was E-O-M-M aging, aging off stream.
Our team was like, our team, our tank, our, like, other DPS and tank were, everyone was selling, basically.
I'll just say that.
We were all, we ain't, we were not setting our best.
I can't anymore.
Okay, there you go.
There's like nothing we could do at that point.
Oh my god, I have to...
No!
I have to reload!
I'm sorry, bro!
If I didn't have to reload, you would be alive right now.
It's like reload issues.
Alright, there you go.
Oh my god, I have to focus so much on...
whole team sold no including me there you go what the fuck all right it's fine what what oh okay whoa whoa here we go I leave now oh oh who said that I am not looking at vc oh no oh he flew so high he flew so high my cabbage is thank you for the twitch prime thank you thank you i need that thing down there is over uh 2000 heals right now it's over 2000 heals If he's like,
bro, I am healing.
I don't know what you're talking about.
2,000 heals is a lot.
Jesus Christ.
I needed to get a load or something.
I'm just like, we don't have a map?
What do you mean?
Now you know, it's been four minutes, and now you notice we don't have a map.
We've been, we've been fucking, Fighting for four minutes now.
Oh my god, and we have an Iron Man, too.
Oh.
All right.
It's fine.
It's not fine, but like, you know, it's fine.
This is like a terrible comp, but it's fine.
This is not the best of comps.
This comp is very special.
sitting on card be careful oh okay you can you can go over and heal with your tiny ass leaves i guess mantis it's just me healed so don't expect much up here yeah why don't you why don't we swap you know what would be great if we okay i'm gonna come back down to one of the poke heals right here all right then i'll i'll do this now
I'll push it a little bit again.
Alright, there, guys.
Guys, I did it, guys.
I pushed the cart.
Oh!
Oh, goodbye.
Don't worry, everyone.
I'm doing the hardest job of all time.
Got scratched myself.
Okay, guys, come back.
You're really far, but you have no heals.
Like, you are in their spawn.
Back up, please.
There we go.
They did it.
They backed up.
Alright.
This is a little...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Um, will you live?
Yes, they didn't charge it up.
Thank god.
Okay.
Three, two, one.
I, I, I healed.
I healed.
I, I healed.
I, I did it.
I saw my fault.
The damage was more get that vehicle moving again
oh my god bro oh my god where's my eye man okay there you up he's alive somehow This is why oh my god, I forgot how fucking so much work you have to do for So much work Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, there's a venom Oh my god,
I thought I hate playing Luna now Oh, please tell me you kid her right okay there you go now i remember like uh why i hate playing luna these days because like you have to be like you have to like be so focused like 24 7.
i thought luna goat what happened luna it's just too much you gotta be like so focused to play her now like you have to be aware 24 7 to play her in in the fucking stressful.
Yeah, no, she is.
And boy, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Yeah, you have to be, like, incredibly aware to make it where.
Well, I hope the Mantis!
Oh, never mind!
I was like, I hope the Mantis doesn't die.
Whoa!
I'm alive.
There you go.
Yeah, you have to make sure you hit majority of your util shit for Luna.
Oh.
Okay.
There we go.
That's unlucky.
I shot it!
You don't have it.
I don't know what else you want me to do!
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, there you go.
There is a widow right here, but who cares, right?
Who cares about that?
There we go.
I am ready to put on a show!
Oh my gosh, the sky that Luna we all hit her like
Guys can we all like shoot her is that too hard
But that boo you know Including which side you're on no after playing rocket Truly 80% of the season I realized why work so hard
Why why work so hard for the same amount of Elo True
Now I understand It's crazy the game got more fun when I stopped caring about about like winning technically can i win cp or no no are you not i still want to win but like it's like if i don't win i'm full of that if i don't win i'm just like oh well no what if i said pretty please i'm just here to have fun I Bro like people When I I bumped into Delaina Like this morning Cause I was playing rank off stream Um Um And I was like Rewatching the stream And he was like Wait is Doki even streaming And like He was in a group call Uh Delaina from 100th ease And they're like No She's just playing for the love of the game Like I don't know It's apparently It's such a wild concept For people to play off stream Like Like,
she's just playing for the love of the game, man.
I do play a lot off-stream.
Just like, you know, I like the...
I like rank.
I like to play off-stream a lot.
Because, you know...
Sometimes I just don't want to...
I just don't want to talk to anyone and just go and just play ring.
That's really it.
There's like no deeper meaning.
I just like playing the game.
I enjoy off-stream and on-stream.
tried to play off stream like when i'm feeling particularly inspired but i want to all right that's fine i don't know oh my god the reload it's fine we're fine we're fine everything is fine also i can't look at chat as much when i'm on luna i just didn't know i always i'm reading chat 70 of time when i'm on rocket
Yeah, but it won't be as fun.
I'm going to use that.
Don't worry, you're fine.
You're so healthy.
Jesus.
Oh my gosh, she's in here.
Me?
What?
Oh my god, okay.
Why is the anvil up?
Why the fuck was he throwing?
Did he not see the fucking mantis?
I was just surprised it was me, you know?
Like, he could have fucked, oh my...
Me again!
Okay.
Me again.
The fucking tunnel vision.
I was just not expecting it again.
You know?
We're going.
I might
be dead from that.
Oh, I'm dead from this!
Okay.
Fuck me, I guess.
I'm getting hurt.
Three times in a row.
You would have got res, but the map broke my res.
That's not bad.
Me again.
Oh, my God.
Okay, okay.
Love battlefield medicine.
This is why I hate playing Luna now.
That was fine.
But thank you.
Bro, this is boring.
You're running triple now.
So there...
So...
Oh my god.
Luna.
Bro, I had to reload.
Okay, if he was yelling at me, I would have been like, I was reloading.
I would have actually used my mic and be like, I was reloading.
I'm on a lead and I'm on a lead.
Wow!
It's like this is a shitty heel cop or some shit.
I got spiked.
I can't do anything when I'm like four people looking at me.
Go out right, go out right, go out right, go out right, go out right.
Someone needs a snowball in the face.
Yeah, we can't touch this.
It's like maybe we need triple support.
Maybe, maybe, maybe.
I don't know.
We might need triple support, guys.
Just a little maybe.
Wouldn't it be wild if we had triple support, guys?
Or maybe not, Mantisius?
We are not getting enough, like, Mantis up for this.
To make this worth it.
I will say it now.
We are undefeatable!
we are definitely oh my god we still have it oh my god we still there you go oh okay look we i got trapped okay look we i got trapped i got trapped Oh, we're gonna summon one right now.
Oh, did we kill him?
Look, I did not have conf- oh.
We must retreat for safety.
Look.
There is a fucking squirrel girl behind us!
Oh my god.
There was a squirrel girl behind us that we didn't look at.
Come back up.
I'm gonna keep trying too much.
I did not realize there was a squirrel girl behind us.
I would not have played like that.
I wanted to save people's lives.
We're trapped.
Bro, I can't It's like maybe Mantis duo here with Luna was not the I was not the key was not the key The current score is three two three see this is why This is why we need triple support
Because I'm not playing Luna anyway It was not fun I'll play Invis If you can play Something else We need long range Just play cop and just run at the widow
I feel like I feel like Not a Luna game Oh my god Now we have a cap Okay we have to play Luna I play Luna and give Captain America The thing Oh that reep Oh, it's Twitch.
I was like, you have replay.
I was like, oh, you got me.
I got one guy.
You got me.
I forgot I was on Twitch for a second.
I was like, what?
But like on Twitch, it's always replay on.
You got me, bro.
Zandra, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
I heard you were an Avenger once.
Yeah, but it didn't last long.
And I burned my ID card.
Forget the card, sir.
Just show us that man who carried it.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
If you turn it off, you turn off VODs.
Holy shit, bro.
That's going to be me.
I laughed at him, so it's going to be me next.
Look, look, like, what will I take?
I need you in front of me.
I can't keep you up, bro.
I'll tell you how to end it.
I'm just going to say, I love you.
at him so I have a feeling I'm gonna be the one that's shot next oh my god it was almost me yeah I'm up here I need heal look here I have oh my god
Oh my god.
I am.
I need to like all of his legs on me.
Bro.
Oh my god, I'm still alive.
I don't know how.
Oh my god, I'm still alive after all that.
Holy shit.
the fuck he went to the other side fucking crazy i don't want to i don't want to peek i'm just gonna stay here still hasn't got me yet i said that he's gonna get me now he's gonna get me isn't he he's good he's gonna get me now guys he's gonna get me isn't he
i'm so scared that you're gonna get me
oh my gosh as long as he doesn't get me
Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on.
Come on, come on.
Oh my god.
Oh god, oh god, we are alive for now.
Oh god.
Hello.
Okay.
We're fine.
Here we go.
We're fine for now.
Yeah!
Oh, thank you.
God.
You know, the play attack.
Take defense.
Thank God.
They surrendered.
That means they were, the other team was yelling at each other so much that they, yeah, they mental boomed.
Thank God.
Bro, oh my God.
I was, I was 20s.
Bro, I mean, he was mad at us.
He was mad at us, but I felt like, oh my God.
it was a lot like I'm just happy we don't have to we don't have to play a defense against that holy shit we meant to boom them thank fucking god yeah I think I'm pretty sure they were flaming each other I'm pretty sure um yeah Daredevil is um these are the bands that are Everyone does for Rivals.
It is Daredevil, Hela, Emma, Scylark,
You can see why we don't have enough fans.
Hey, Gully.
What else?
Other than that, I think that's it.
Like, these are the six.
I bet you got Mantis.
Do you have everyone uploads?
is that everything daredevil jeff emma silok bucky hella oh venom seven bands these are the seven bands that everyone does for this season uh so yeah uh that's what we have uh so we don't have enough bands for all seven of these it's because like they didn't really do much to to nerf Bucky but because they nerfed everything else it made Bucky so strong and then you gotta make sure also like for bands you gotta like you know do 5d chess just making sure like maybe the other team won't ban that character and so you're not gonna get all seven like you know we only have four bands and maybe maybe in the end we get two bands because we all ban the same thing because you don't know what the other team is gonna be banning
isn't as a Jeff main Jeff gets his ult too fast it's not even his alt it's literally his his heel the fact that his heel does piercing um like because like you know if you don't have a jeff and the enemy team has a jeff it's so oppressive that's the main reason why jeff is like really difficult right now and why people ban him because like getting a good jeff alt is also really difficult in this elo just because like you know everyone tends to save their cooldowns and stuff against the jeff eat so It's,
like, really hard to make it work.
It's really not hard to make, but it's really hard to be good at Jeff in this Elo.
Because if you're going against, like, you know, like, you know, you have to be careful of the mag.
The bubbles, the mag bubbles, the mag up, the DPS we were ulting as well.
Hello, everyone.
Oh, my God.
We made a cage.
Okay.
Dance for us in this.
Oh, my God.
Dance.
Come on.
But, do you...
Do you have the dance emote?
Oh, no!
I provided the ball.
The mag came over to save me.
The mag was like, begun.
Alright, I played a Luna game, so this is my rocket game.
game now oh i forgot oh whoops i forgot to put that toggle off give me a sec gotta fix this
all right the mag was just was just trying to protect the mantis he's like she was just a small time girl
He's like, we gotta save her.
Oh, hey, we have just Mia support.
That's cool.
I'm cool with that.
Yeah, I'm cool with that, guys.
Yeah, they're saving her from us Hollywood types.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Alright, hey guys.
Don't worry.
Technically, we have two supports, me and the group.
Oh, yeah, I like how this guy just thought about if I should...
It's like, you know what?
Starlord.
Ha ha ha.
Escape pod ready.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Alright, here we go.
Orenkis the Celestio, too.
It's alright.
It's decent rank in this Evo.
Yeah.
Obviously, Eternity is the top 500 right now, right?
Low Eternity is top 500.
It's crazy.
Like, so little, like, this season, like, last season, everyone was fucking climbing so hard last season.
This season, it's, like, barely...
I think you should go top right.
Don't tell that.
barely every anyone climbed this season it's because it's not dragon it's not the dragon icon everyone was like wanted the dragon icon no one wants the peach which is understandable it's understandable why no one wanted that what happened to our in this where's our where's our team why did we go this way I'm so confused no everyone was climbing so hard for the dragon badge but no one's climbing as much for the peach one I think it's also cuz like ignite dude everyone was like not playing ring because you know everyone has to practice for the one million dollar tournament anyway so like that's made sense everyone wanted that wouldn't no one was touching ring oh don't worry i'm chucking my heels i should play again what didn't we say we're gonna go top right why are we still going top right
oh yeah he's dead dead all right guys like i'm going top right i'm going top right why whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I wanted us to move up but nobody moved up okay I am not the problem here like we are so why are we going right side you can touch the point I'll break from the third time like what going right side why are we okay right side never worked for us guys okay this is right side's not it i will say that right side is not it right side is not it look at that luna bro she'll be punished this right i am ready to put on a show play at
Wait, unless...
Unless right side is...
Oh my god, wait, right side is the...
Oh my god, wait, I guess I'll...
You know what, I'll eat my words.
You know what?
As an adult, I know when I'm wrong.
Maybe he was right.
You know, being an adult means that you know when you are wrong.
Right was right.
And I will have to admit that he might have been right that right side was the right way to go See I can grow as a person and know when I'm wrong guys I can grow as a person I know when I'm wrong.
I know I can admit when I'm wrong Wait, what the fuck?
What the?
Oh my god.
Alright.
Nice.
We're all alive.
We should be fine.
We should be fine theoretically.
I go back one, team.
Oh my god.
Please.
Strange is still on...
Oh, Strange is not on the card anymore.
No gold.
left.
There's not even is there's not even a left
look at us go guys wow you see you see how relaxing it is compared to compared to how I had to how it was like playing Luna guys you see how relaxing this is like oh my god it's like I'm at walking at a park right No, I don't think so.
He's so good.
Hey guys, I think they're TPing.
No, I don't think so as a portal fucking opens up.
It's like a different game.
Guys, I don't think...
Oh my god.
Bro, oh my god.
Okay, I thought he was still behind us.
What the fuck?
Change one, change one, change one.
Is he still one?
Is he like one inside in the room with us right now?
They won't win.
Oh, yeah, buddy.
Oh, yeah, yippee.
Only if you have...
Wait, Johnny G?
Wait, what?
Wait, from Overwatch?
What?
Johnny G from Overwatch?
Bro.
Do they, like, know every- everyone knows each other, bro?
Johnny G from Overwatch.
What a fuck is Johnny G?
No, I'm lying.
I have no idea what you're talking about.
I have no idea who you're stuck.
Dude, there's so many Johnny G's apparently.
Apparently Johnny G's everywhere.
Oh my god, okay.
Nice.
Where's our M12?
They're in here.
I have to put it in there.
Bro, hey guys, he's strange all day.
See, we might strange,
though.
Oh.
I like how we went outside of our Invisalte there.
Look, I didn't want my amp to get destroyed, guys.
Well, that's where she dies.
We too.
We grew up.
I don't want to commit anything.
Hello.
Is everybody...
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
Guess I'll go this way.
Alright, it's time.
Are they not?
They're not going dive.
Alright, time to play a different game now.
Time to play hard mode.
Alright, no more casual.
La-di-da.
Time to actually play the game.
Yeah, time to sit up straight.
No more slouching.
Unfortunately, it's gamer hours now.
Oh, I just hope he, oh, oh.
What the fuck?
Oh,
my god, okay.
All right.
Thank god I got the ice freeze.
I will say, if I didn't get the ice freeze, we could have lost that.
100% or like I wouldn't have been able to live like I needed that ice freeze to like be alive are you serious no you better fucking live
all right back on rocket duty if I make it technically I should be tp-ing but yay technically never punished yay i didn't get punished i don't know how to tp i'm worried i'm gonna get up with the trigger yell at me i i rather than yell at me we're not TPing.
Then they yell at me for fucking up the TP.
It's the little things, chat.
It's the tiny things.
Yeah, the thing is, if I fuck up the TP, like, everyone will see how bad the TP is.
Like, if I, like, accidentally, like, put it in the wrong place or, like, like, And I could be like, oh, I thought someone else would TP.
I could literally say that.
But then everyone will see me fuck up my TP.
And I don't want to deal with that.
I'd rather everyone see me, not know, forgot to pick Strange.
Coincidentally, I forgot to pick him.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
All right.
I'll go, I'll rock it first because I don't know if they'll go dive.
That's the thing.
Oh my god, I swear to God, if our Invis was like to the right just a little bit, he could have got headshot.
You're actually gonna get a headshot there.
That's crazy.
He was that close.
All right.
They're not going dive, so I can't believe they're going to have to.
That's good to know, you know.
Oh, never mind.
I can do... I can play against Captain on Luna.
Oh, goodbye.
Yeah, this is the stress stream.
I'm not here to get more stressed out, guys.
It's fine.
Yay!
Easiest game of my life.
I stay until I lose the game.
There is a... Whoa, whoa, whoa.
You know, that could have been me.
See that Envis woman that's getting like absolutely fucked fucked up on by captain?
That could have been me, but instead I'm out here.
Oh my god, I knew I heard something.
There is a Captain America behind us, but we're not gonna think about that, I guess.
All right.
That's fine.
Don't make me all.
If I get yelled at for ulting there to save my own life, don't make me do it.
Don't make me do it.
If I am about to die, I will throw this all down.
Okay, I'll let our...
Okay, our Invis is trying to find the cap.
You should be building your alt right now, sir.
Right.
Yeah, yeah, Raccoon is an auto- No, Raccoon is an auto-clicker.
Luna is Toho.
I agree.
Yo, do not am.
Don't am.
Just kite, kite, trust, trust, trust, trust.
Okay.
If I get back and we have Invisal first, Invisal first.
Hey guys.
Hey!
So what was the plan?
Guys, what was the plan that we had?
I thought we, I felt like we had a great plan that we drafted out.
Yeah, yeah, I will say.
I thought that we were, you know, I thought we had a plan, guys.
What?
I like how none of the plan, none of what we were.
we had on the plan worked out in the end.
We didn't get anything going in there.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
What happened to our...
What's wrong?
We're solved.
Alt, alt, alt, alt, alt, alt.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, we don't need it.
We don't need it.
I am very surprised we lived.
There was a big chance that we were not going to live there.
I'm very surprised.
We should not have lived there.
simple geometry I have a plan that step one has failed step one invisible invisible first somehow we somehow failed step one it's actually crazy there was five steps in this plan but yeah we failed the first step
all right
no this is for me this is de-stressful because it's like it's i'm using video games to escape from reality this is escapism
oh where it's like 10 it's not that late you should play it play this like later it has one shirt exactly Hey, so are we okay?
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
There we go.
We did plan one this time.
We did step one.
Thank God.
I'm glad.
I'm glad we didn't fail step one.
Thank God.
Because we did it.
We did step one.
See, if I was Luna, if I was Luna, I'd be dead by now.
I went and climbed the way.
Alright.
It's not too late.
Only if I keep playing.
E-he.
Got two.
Okay, I think.
They're just gonna.
They're gonna shoot it.
But like.
You know, we have our little bit of HP though.
And there's one.
There's one.
Oh Nope, that's fine.
That's fine Where did my thing go?
Oh, that's fine.
Watch this.
He's back He's back.
Oh My god.
Oh my god.
Oh My what is go oh there we go.
I died I That's fine.
All right, our Invis is okay.
Our Invis is okay.
I don't know about our Bucky, but...
Don't worry, Johnny G!
I got my Rez!
Oh, no.
Oh, no, we died with...
We died with up.
Oh, no, not anymore!
I used the Rez.
Oh, that is bad.
Okay, that is okay.
Okay, that is not good.
That is not good.
I didn't think they will all shoot it.
Wait, unless?
Oh, unless!
Wait, wait, they're winning!
I always believe.
Yay!
We did it.
We did it, guys.
He's not.
No, alright.
That's how it is.
See, isn't it good that I didn't portal?
And Samra, thank you for the 150s, thank you, thank you.
Keeper, thank you for the Twitch Prime, thank you, thank you.
Who's Tato?
Potato?
GG, my bad.
This guy?
Who's this guy?
What the fuck is Tato?
All part of the plan, see?
All part of the plan.
I don't need a portal.
i'm just a dumb old support player i don't know what i'm doing i just hold that right click
t he
oh yeah don't worry guys i'll practice street fighter don't worry i'll make sure i'll be ready tomorrow i am a little scared i'm trying not to feel the thing is i also don't want to like practice too much because i practice too much i get in my own head too like i get i get two in my head so i'm trying to be more more like casual about it too because i don't want to like uh too too much practice that i get so stressed out about it so i'm taking a more relaxed approach because i am i am practicing i'm trying you know i i like you know range uh sessions and everything i coaches and stuff i did play rank off stream but i don't want to get two in my head as well i'll I'll make a custom lobby later,
too, to practice against the characters.
Okay, these people are actually fighting.
I'm trying to, like, fucking try and find roleplayers.
But these guys are, like, these guys are harassing me.
That's it.
Where are my roleplay servers?
Do you end up learning another character?
No, I'm just gonna be the Honda.
I think the thing is, all three...
I have to play a character that acts...
Like, the thing is, Zeng Yi?
It gets hard countered by all three of those characters.
That's the thing.
Like, there's no...
Because, like, if I have to learn their character, like, obviously the easiest would be Zengief for me because I already play it.
But, like, Juri, Aki, and Ryu, all hard counters Zengief.
Like, because he has...
They all have spam.
And I struggle the most against spam characters.
yeah he's tough um just grabs him bro
i do well against character like i do well against characters that don't have fireball
oh i mean i could play in this you know i'll play in this i'll do in this i have no guys i have one day there's no way I'm learning a fucking character like a different character in one day that hard counters those three
yeah but uh I mean I just think I my goal was to win one game that's like when uh one game if I win one game I'm happy that's that's that's it I'm going in with low expectations And, well, the thing is, I can't say not last because it depends on my team as well.
And I don't know how my team's going to, I don't know how my team's going to do in general overall.
Because the only, the issue is that, um, the issue, the biggest issue that I noticed was that half the roster for the Capcom tournament is in Seijam Slam.
And I've noticed that majority of players that are in the Seijam Slam 2XKO tournament, have been practicing QXHL versus Street Fighter.
So I don't know how they are going to be like in Street Fighter.
Like, you know, I have, like, you know, the previous St. John Slams and the previous streams they've done.
But, like, I don't know how they're going to be like for...
Not just...
No, my team.
I have one player on my team that's in the QXHL.
But apparently, QXHL is so fucking complicated and, like, really tilting to practice on for those who are like...
it's like it's a tag team so yeah it has different inputs and it's a tag team i was watching a little bit and apparently everyone's like so fucking mad at t-mo or some shit because he's like extremely spammy and everything everyone was like god damn it if i wasn't playing a t-mo oh everyone was i just everyone was just complaining about t-mo i don't understand why because i don't understand t-scale but it's like a whole different breed of like fighting games in terms of difficulty and also like what i noticed is that in 2xpo when they get that one combo off they just die i was like watching because i was watching a little bit because i was like curious and literally this guy was like one hp and the enemy team was full hp he hit he he like got one string of combo and it was over like the other team lost i was so surprised i was so fucking surprised I was like,
what do you mean the other team?
Yeah, it's apparently very easy too
Like it was like he literally Yeah, there was like one-shot combos or something
So that's like really scary IMO that the game is like that
Stay up here hulking and just stay back there
It seems very tilting when especially the tag team aspect because apparently in the tag team aspect It's like even more like tilting with the and the chip damage too
Are you seeing I'm using leverless
Oh no three oh god thank god okay thank god
All right There you go push them away Hello.
There we go.
That's crazy.
I was outside of that.
Yeah, that was bullshit.
I saw myself outside the ring and I still got hit.
I was like, are you serious?
I was not expecting that.
I swear to God, it looked like I was outside too.
That's what, that was like, what the fuck?
I was like, Hey guys, um, there is a big man that wants to fucking beat me up right now.
Yeah, I don't like Jeff's a lot.
Alright, I'll push the cart.
Well, never mind, I go...
Don't kill him.
We can charge our ult.
Oh wait, we already have ult.
Yeah, I was gonna say we have a lot of ult.
You're halfway there.
Keep going!
Yeah.
But it seems very tilting.
I saw a lot of people that were like super tilted.
Because of the combo shit.
Oh shit.
Okay, I got scared.
Oh my god, I'm getting very scared.
Oh my god, I only used that up because I got scared of the Hella.
Why was there a double alt line?
Oh yeah, why was there?
They do have... Okay, the Hella didn't get the alt off.
Okay, the Hella died.
Yeah.
So like, I don't know.
I don't know how the too much tournament is gonna be like to be fair.
only just because like like I said like I said like a lot of people that are in the Capcom tournament they're also
they're also like in the 2x KO so I don't know how people are gonna whoa maybe yay I'm in my own this where did everyone go oh I was like I swear to God there was like a lot of people on that cart like what happened if you try and stall your old double voice sign yeah oh that's what happened to him I was so confused I was like I was like did you oh my god still you're up for three seconds and if you do it all double voice lines
no one man i understand not who those are all right i just don't want to die to the hell out honestly we had to kill him before like before he does um you know the uh there hello okay there you go all right we're fine what the fuck okay we're fine for real all right they still have armed and dangerous and again oh and that too i forgot about that get him out of here i'll push him who is over there in the enemy okay there you all right there you have still have watch it's gonna happen oh never mind johnny g couldn't get it just stand there and take headshot damage all right should be a lot of healing all right there you go yay
no more again no more again time to switch things up including which side you're on kind of um should only be yeah no i'm saying like i don't know how my team is going to do against the other teams because like everyone's been focused on practicing because half the tournament has say jam slams 2x ko tournament as in the 2x ko tournament and all of the majority of them have been practicing have been practicing for the 2x ko tournament because that like a lot of the players haven't played that game before so um they all have been like they all have been like on training for that so I don't know the skill level like I don't know if my team will be better or worse like that's what I'm saying like I know I'm fighting the other beginners but also like the one player the one player um that I'm scared of is the one that is not a beginner because you have to fill in for someone that had to drop out last minute but she's not um but she's like she's been playing for a while point one second your
head is zero yeah they practice 2x heal I practice mob arrivals so I'm that's the the person I'm scared of the most the not baby yeah I'm in the baby category but I have to fight like a teenager it's like yeah it's like it's like a baby fight and then a teenage and then one of them's a teenager
oh what the what who's who's shooting me just take some headshot damage and i should be allowed to like okay like he is baby boost right now like guys i don't think you want him to take headshot damage unless you're saying group i was gonna say like you should not be taking damage we have another tank now thank god yeah that's why i'm like not stressing out too much like i did for sayjam um because i know if i take it too seriously it's gonna affect how i play too like i'm gonna get like so stressed out to get like super stressed out about it so whatever happens happens i'm in wait after this after bravo's i'll practice more history credit
also this isn't tech but this is just information they've nerfed jeff 13 times and given them four buffs jesus christ went back you know this is a Jeff me why would you keep track oh no you think they know I'm here using oh my guys bro we're in a fight I can't listen to Jeff fun facts right now I who's who's crosshair was that what the fuck's crosshair was that he's like fun fact while we're all getting like tech stop i'm gonna i want to unsubscribe to the jeff fun facts
please bro i'm like i'm trying to fucking poke it like we were in like the fucking crazy match here crazy fight here and he's like also by the way
Okay.
We're gonna have Jeff up soon at least.
You can tell he's a Jeff main too, the way he's playing.
Oh my.
Alright.
That's fine.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my.
Oh!
Please.
Please work.
Alright, there you go.
We got it.
Oh my god, everyone was taking so much damage there.
I am so surprised we won that fight in the end.
That was so much damage.
Oh!
Everyone was taking so much damage.
Yep, they're TPA.
I don't think they know I'm behind.
They don't know I'm right.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God, wait.
Also, another techie.
Oh, Jeff is riding her back and she doesn't jump.
Oh, Jeff, his strength hits him no matter what, because of how the hell I'll do this.
I don't say this often.
I'm so fast.
I don't say this often, but I think Jeff is this hyper fixation.
I
Awesome Fun fact guys I I have a feeling that Jeff is his Hyper fixation Holy hell of this All of you just hit all our shots on me That's crazy We lost the fight and he's like By the way guys here's another Fun Jeff deck
All right.
It was a very fun fact.
I learned a lot from this one guy.
Oh shit, nice.
I'll help him out with this little war.
All right.
We're good, we're good.
Hints, I'm waiting there for us for a tank.
I'm getting a hundred meter old.
Was there a up you mean?
Yeah.
Well, they're dark cow.
Disappear.
Oh my god.
Hit me.
What do you think?
Okay.
What?
Okay, I'm alive
I'm just as surprised as you guys I am just a surprise I
The recovery see this is Street Fighter see
Look at that recovery recovery.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, that was a huge shift for me.
Oh, I couldn't get to you, but I have this.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, like a shark attack survivor.
Don't win yet.
I mean, do you have any more Jeff facts?
Let's, you know, we can enable him a little bit more.
Shout out to his fun facts, Fun facts are neat.
Yeah, I should have thrown so we could hear more facts from him.
Guys, I don't think he has any more.
I think he left already i mean um goodbye or good old fun facts i'm gonna use the bathroom i'll be right back guys
did he he didn't give us any more facts oh maybe those were all it that's why he told us more fun facts when we died in our fight it's like i gotta squeeze one more in before they all before they all go.
He only does, yeah.
He only, yeah.
No, he only does live shows.
He wants us to hear the fun facts.
It ain't the same when you're reading it, guys.
It's not the same.
He needs it.
It has to be verbal only.
I like how the son of Jesus Christ asked me how old I am.
Why does Jesus want me to dox myself?
Huh?
You can ask me that in heaven.
Oh, he's like the son of Jesus.
Yeah, you can ask me that in heaven, bro.
Mr. Six, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Yeah, dad is barking.
I have no idea why.
Let's open the Luna now.
I'll go check on him.
I'll be back again.
I gotta check on him.
Who am I going to banish from this match?
This won't be in my room.
I still want to be in my room.
He's like, no!
I think it's just because my room is too hot for him.
I'll be surprised if that's the reason why.
I feel a little too hot.
Oh yeah, but if you guys can, please feel free to nominate me as Best Marvel Rival Streamer.
I would really appreciate it a lot.
guys it will mean alive i can get nominated um what i'm scared right now is literally the panel vote which is why i've been streaming um because they're like it's not popular vote to be nominated because they're like oh we don't want to make sure like you know we don't want to uh make it just a popular vote so i'm just scared that the panel wouldn't put me in because i don't have you know rival streamers stream it like every day and I like I talk about rivals every day and like for free I look I get free publicity by talking about rivals in other streams so I feel like that makes me more qualified to be the best Marvel rival streamer because I would mention rivals in different games and I feel that that makes me the best Marvel rival streamer like I might not play Marvel rivals a lot I do play a lot I might not stream it a lot but it's always a part of my stream in one way or another yeah yeah
I advertise it to the variety audience which is more important than advertising it to the rivalous audience because like it's like non-rival play it might make non-rival players be aware of Marvel Rivals
so if anything if anything I should be nominated
exactly exactly Yeah, I hope I hope I can I hope I'm in the nominations That's uh, that's why I'm trying That's why I've also been streaming it so the people who um So the people who are at the panel when they pull up my channel and they don't know who I am They'll be like Yeah,
she does stream in like you know I want to see and be like oh, yeah, no she does stream rivals like she ain't making that up
Oh my god, there is a...
What did I put on my YouTube?
My YouTube also has rivals.
It might not be as much.
But also, like, majority of the people on the panel are...
I will say majority of people on the panel, I will assume that they are Twitch people.
So they would look at the Twitch first.
oh my god i don't know if i i have to yeah i don't think i can play like a other other support i'm like thinking if i should play jesus christ i'm even clapping
what the fuck the phoenix doesn't have alt yet phoenix isn't playing like Oh, chicken?
Please, I have to reload.
Oh my god.
Oh, oh, we got it.
Oh, oh, I knew it.
I knew I had to get away.
Oh, no.
I got stunned in my class.
That sucks.
Because we didn't know for the stars.
I don't think we're winning those guys.
I don't think.
Alright, we're going to Maybe.
Alright, because we're all like standing in a straight line, so maybe this will help.
Okay.
Alright, it's fine, it's fine.
It's not fine because the Starlord is...
Yo, are you real?
What the fuck was that?
oh my god the starlord is still behind us we have not killed the starlord yet and i'm scared because of that the
fact that like that starlord is still there
jesus christ all right maybe we have to i'm not standing in there
You know what they're gonna do next?
Oh, wait, never mind.
But they're still gonna do that next.
They're gonna do the Star Lord next.
That's what I'm scared about.
Oh, oh, that is.
Get ready for legendary, guys.
Oh, oh, next fight, next fight, next fight.
It's gonna happen next fight.
I have to either build my alt first or we're gonna get legendary.
Yeah, I knew the moment that Punisher was gonna, oh, like I was, I'm not standing next to him.
Like, it's the only reason.
Get ready.
He's coming.
He's gonna do it.
Get ready.
He's trying to flank.
I can feel it.
Why don't I?
He's gonna be like, legendary.
It's coming.
Guys, guys, guys.
All eyes over here.
please I wait that's not legendary what is this that's not legendary what the fuck that's that was that was Emma cross oh he's gonna use it now I don't know why like why would you push up I can't use no there you go legendary there you go there it is I I didn't want to use it for that exact reason that was the reason why I didn't want to use it it was right there oh god I was like,
why are you guys so aggressive?
I really only have one ult.
It's like, yeah, well, if we win that, if we win that fight, he's just going to use legendary anyway.
Oh my god, I should have just used it.
Three are clicking Punisher.
I should have just used it.
I was, I didn't think that, you know, he was going to ult that.
I don't know.
I didn't think he was gonna run into the Invis ult with it.
I thought I don't know I legitimately thought like we all know we have to save my ult for Starlord Because no matter what I we will not live a Starlord ult Oh our fucking venom is dead
God, oh God does he don't I don't think he knows.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, there it is!
There it is!
That's why!
That's why we have to save it!
Oh my god.
Wow, it's like the moment.
The moment that he was lit.
legendary.
It's over for us.
Oh, why did our venom leave?
I needed the ult charge.
Why did you leave?
I'm really... Oh, my God.
If our venom played with me, I could have got my ult.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
He lives for that.
At least he's allowed for that, you know?
Please kill the mag.
I will do it myself and we have to.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
That was close.
Yeah, that was close.
I was just like, Invisible Woman, guys.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
That's the hard part.
I want to hold up, but I also know, like, for the fucking legendary, but then my team is inting.
It's the worst part.
D-Barrant, thank you for the 200 biddies, thank you, thank you.
Variety watchers be like, oh, Marvel Rivals?
Never heard of that game.
Exactly!
And that's why I should be nominated as one of the best Marvel Rivals streamer.
Because I'm literally advertising the game in other streams that are not Marvel Rivals.
rivales.
That's why I hope the panel the panel of judges notice that.
I mean, like, I'm trying to go in with low expectations because I feel like you know, I feel like that's why that's one of the reasons why I wouldn't be nominated, you know?
That's one of the reasons why I think I won't be nominated just because of that.
So yeah, I don't care about winning.
I just wanted me up there.
Four, three, two one all you need to do is capture the mission area got it me there's a lot of people that deserves to be nominated too that's the thing there's also like a lot because if it was four people i can already like think of like four people that's not me getting nominated
oh i hope i save the venom venom
Where's...
Oh, I was gonna say, where's our Emma?
We don't have an Emma.
I guess we don't need an Emma, question mark.
We don't need an Emma, I guess.
That's fine.
Jesus Christ, what's going on in this hole?
Woo!
I guess we still don't need an Emma.
Oh my god, we're both like sharing all children
Okay, that's good because I was about to up the thing guy
I'm really worried about the the Emma though.
Oh, there you go Nice I can scratch myself
All right.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
I did not expect all four of them to be there.
I thought they left.
I thought all these guys left already.
All right.
I'm scared.
That's okay.
I think our venom will not be okay, but that's okay.
Jesus Christ, there's so many things going on.
Oh my god, venom!
You really want to feed them all I know But please Chill for like five seconds That's right You can't protect them now That's right You guys like that Oh I hope that Bucky's okay Oh my god he lives that I think there were like 20 people in that Oh Okay We're passively pushing the cart Okay How is he still...
Oh my god.
Okay, they're 5.
They're still 5.
You know what?
I'm gonna do something crazy.
Watch this.
I'm dead.
Oh my god.
I don't think that was supposed to happen.
Oh shit.
You're fucking crazy.
What?
Okay, buddy.
What the fuck?
Bro.
No, we, bro.
I don't know what that was.
I, I, I, I don't know what that was.
Honestly, that was wild.
You know what would be easier if we haven't guys?
I feel like the game would be a lot easier.
We had an Emma.
Just an FYI.
Jesus Christ.
I had to use that.
I think I would have 100% died.
If I didn't.
Okay.
I am a little bit worried.
I don't think we're gonna win this.
That's why I am a little bit worried.
just a little bit just the teensy weency little bit okay okay okay that's that's good that's good never oh my where did he come from hey guys there is like a fucking random wolverine thank god I was like where the fuck did this guy come from Oh, I missed it.
Sorry, I had to go hog around.
I could have saved the person on low ground, but that's not the fun part.
Oh, yeah, no.
Okay, thank God.
If he hits me while I'm invisible, I will report him.
I would 100% report that.
you actually was not hacking like
bro i swear to god bro i swear to god if you die i swear to god
bro he's up okay we're all shooting where are you oh no please stop barking please All right, get ready.
Get ready.
Oh, there is legendary.
There is legendary.
There is higher feet.
Legendary can exist right here.
Okay, but what if we do our own legendary?
You're right.
Hey, guys.
I'm going to let him.
Because we need that for a ledge.
Okay, we have legendary counter.
All right.
that's fine it's fine
goodbye we got him oh we did it thank god we did it
we fucking did it i was like please please we gotta win this before the legendary comes out
yeah yippee kira thank you for the 100 biddies thank you thank you yes the infamous god of War Street.
That is true.
We did it!
Yay!
We're gaming!
I think I'm playing pretty well.
You're right, they should have surrendered so I could have more time.
More time to queue up more games.
I don't know why he's so barky.
It's because he knows that, like, he knows they can't do anything about it because i would just ignore him so like and then he would be like oh yeah if i don't bark it like barking does like she can um i don't get anything if i'm barking but now now that i got a noise complaint i always have to like check up on him yeah he's rage baiting me he fucking knows i don't know his his water bowl is full he has his dinner yeah he barks for the love of the game he just wants my attention i think he's just attention barking which is what a do you can count on me all right oh nice no one's dead yet no one's dead this is rp survey my favorite but yeah i don't know why they're all in dps and not not the cool ones
hello everyone hello oh wait you're oh my god wait you haven't wait wait you have the money okay okay okay okay wait she has the money she has the money which means oh come on guys we're all here to put on a shoulder you guys see that no my poor
bro that's messed up that's so messed up i worked so hard to pry that pull i worked so hard okay i gotta check up on him guys all right give me a sec i go check up on him again what more bad guys just what we need
oh sweet moves right oh he's trying to get more food from me i didn't throw his can i didn't throw his can yet so he was like he was like he walked over to the empty can of food and um and he was like Food?
Where's food?
Where is it?
Who am I going to banish from this match?
I'm like, there is no food.
He's so greedy.
I haven't played Art Raiders yet.
I want to play it next week, though.
But I want to take two days off on Sunday and Monday.
Just because, like...
I heard so it's really fun But I think the hardest part is just finding people to play Play it with, you know Only has three stack for it But like I need to find people who play FPS games For it I did ask like I asked Altair if he wants to Play it But I don't know if he can I gotta wait for that,
you know Purms
I know they have Purms But you know they have the I need to wait to see like if he can play with me
Oh we didn't in the second one pick your hero or villain i'm not judging
um i'm not the time luna snow like the moon i shine in darkness but yeah let's see let's see guys let's see
next week i don't know my schedule yet we're definitely gonna finish batman next week we're gonna finish the batman series next week and then um we do have a sponsor too.
I can't say what the sponsor is yet.
This is one of their sponsors where like, when they announce it, I can announce it.
So, so I got, oh wait, I do have a sponsor next week.
It's really nice though.
It's, it's really nice though to, you know, be able to have, uh, uh, sponsor streams every other week or so.
Because, you know, they're like additional income type, you And, you know, companies like it when I show their stuff, which makes me happy.
Makes me happy that companies like it when I, you know, advertise their things.
It means I'm marketable.
It makes me happy.
And I think, and I hope that you guys have fun, too.
Even if it's a sponsor stream.
I hope you guys enjoy.
Oh, they have a Venom.
I'm getting off Venom.
I'm doing Animal Crossing.
fucking fighting that Jesus Christ I didn't hurt our sila oh yeah no I'm I'm going animal crossing no I I'm going Jeff oh that does not seem fun I like how I I like how I froze I froze the venom and like doesn't matter Anyone have a mic?
I don't know.
I lied confidently.
Oh my god.
That was such a big lie.
Has our Spider-Man done anything yet?
I don't know.
I don't think our Spider-Man has done it.
Well, to be fair, our entire team hasn't done anything yet.
Other than us killing.
Oh my god, we did something!
Four of them over here.
Hello.
Get ready to get eaten.
Oh, goodbye.
This is where we die.
No, I...
No, zero kill.
The Spider-Man had the fucking snowflake the entire time.
and we did nothing with it so I'm swapping off of Luna that should yeah be fair the other map is better for spider-man I hate this map because it's so laggy I'm begging bro
all right did they get him did they get him
Jesus, what happened?
Oh my, no, this map sucks.
This map fucking sucks.
This map gives the most raindrops.
I don't know why.
Look at that.
Oh, it's so gross.
It's so gross.
This map, for some reason, is so poorly optimized.
It's so poorly optimized.
I have a 550 90 and I still get like that's that is such insane brain drop.
Like I should not be getting brain drops like this.
That's fine.
Please all before we start dying here.
Is that what you want guys?
Also did that because they have Phoenix up too.
of us now oh my god i wanted to save it for invis but for a punish build because i knew that you'll have to keep fighting until we have a winner no the frame drop is like really bad i should
oh no i should went low key there my previous team there's only one person that was from my previous team and he was the dps that's now in support i don't know what you're ulting what the fuck they said they said use all before whoever said use up before they uh i heard that before you attack get ready
we all heard that right who said that who said that who said that that wasn't me I got one guide by my own team four three two one I That wasn't me someone one guide me
We all heard that right they're like use all before they we they all Who was it you all heard that right?
We did right you all heard that and then they blamed me Then no one confessed to you And then no one fucking confessed to it fucking cowards oh I bet you it was the guy that was a big fan, but why the fuck did you love that?
You did that.
You...
You didn't confess.
I bet it was you.
You and you didn't even confess.
We know you said it.
I've old.
okay i was like okay whoever said that i'll listen
i was just being a good soldier
there we go
there we go i can die oh yeah yeah you saw that rocket all sitting into without phoenix who did oh but no one calls him out
no one fucking calls him out for ulting the phoenix oh but oh i was just being a good soldier yeah and then he was like big fan but what the fuck were you doing excuse me
i'm killing a little killing them.
Okay.
Control lost.
Their team's capture progress has passed the halfway point.
Kidding.
God damn it.
I even get one guide on my own team.
I even get one guide in a team game.
That's right.
Exactly.
You would take the blame.
Even if it was my fault.
Oh my god.
Alright.
That's looking right.
Oh my god.
God damn it.
Goodbye.
Okay, you're an actual dragon would one guy me.
Oh, where's he?
Oh my god.
Oh,
he was one.
Okay, I almost got him.
He was one, too.
I'm so sad.
At least my team got him.
No, I should have just went in this instantly.
I thought I would eat someone else, but went for me.
I don't even know who is.
He's shit talking to.
It can't be me because I won my last four games.
That's why I changed it when, uh, you're terrible.
Okay, no, our Spider-Man, I don't know if our Spider-Man did anything.
I, oh, no, I'm sorry, bro.
I know you said big fan, but like, I'm sorry.
Wait, actually, 4K?
Okay, no, actually, no, you did your best.
You had 12K.
No, four, I just noticed.
No, I'm sorry.
No, you did.
did your vest but also you one guide me um but also 4k from the spider bed also fuck him if i can't be like uh be like what the fuck are you doing in this and i was like did you not hear what we i just heard i wasn't crazy right they did say all before we died right before we they all someone said that right I heard that and I was just like okay I all
I'm not going crazy right I wasn't hearing my voices right like we were all there okay the receipt yeah
yeah and I was the only one with the thing is I I remember pressing tab, and only me and Rocket had us.
So I was like, I assumed he was talking about us, because I looked at her.
Oh, I pressed tab, and I was like, okay, he's talking about us, right?
Because only Rocket and I had us.
So, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay, good.
I'm not going crazy.
I thought I was going crazy.
No, I just thought, I was like, what the fuck?
Like, why did everyone blame me?
Did we not hear the same cop?
I just need to know if I'm going crazy or not.
I need to know if I'm getting gaslit, guys.
Because I'm the one that's supposed to do the gaslighting.
Not them.
I had to know if I was getting gaslit or not.
Hey, guard the galaxy, sure.
But sometimes we take stuff other people are guarding.
And then I was explained it and then no one said anything No one was like, yeah, I heard that too Like no one defended me Like they're like Everyone just Everyone just stopped talking after I said that So I was like, I'm not going crazy Why did I didn't know what Why did no one back me up
They got scared Yeah They were in on it.
They were in on it.
The only thing that can cheer me up is to dance.
This is the only way.
I'm just enjoying the- What the fuck, bro!
I'm trying to dance!
Why?
It's fine.
They just got him.
What do you mean they got him?
They just, yeah, they just got him.
And the one and done.
Refuse to elaborate.
You want to come in?
No?
No.
I don't have food.
Okay.
He wants to use my bed, I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, I got him banned.
He broke my pole, and now he's gone.
What the fuck?
Who shot me?
What the fuck shot me?
Bro, toss defenses.
I wasn't even armed.
Oh, I wasn't even shot.
I just got beat up to death.
Okay.
That's different.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Alright, here we go.
Alright, let's be a little bit stressed out by playing Luna.
Oh yeah, no, Jeff Miff sucks on this map.
I agree.
No, get him out of here.
He's sucking.
He's so oppressive on this map.
He's so good at, like, cough maps in general.
Get that guy out of here.
it's so interesting to see people do the um what is it the meta the new twitch meta where um everybody like all the the i guess like um semi small to semi big streamers just combine their view accounts together so they can be on top of the page it's so like i mean that's really smart that's really smart because when you're on the top of the category you know people just click on the first stream usually yeah collab but no collab love the name dad oh his name i named my dog after myself which is doki because i guess i'm an eagle maniac uh i just i love myself so much that i named them after myself so um but and then like i i call him like doki Doge or do it like sometimes I call him as amber like before then um and so I was like oh I'll call him doky amber doge um but so and then people were like oh that's abbreviated it's dad yeah everyone's like oh my god that's dad and that's just easier to say you know because so so like people won't get confused between me Dokey bird the bird and
doky doge the dog so you know when I say Doki, like, people will know, oh, she's talking about herself.
When I say, dad, people will know I'm talking about my dog.
All right, here we go.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
Oh, I hope fucking or walking doesn't kill you.
rocket all right we chill chill like that we just take this corner because we chill like that and then i do like patty cake in the corner too because we're all still oh what the fuck okay i move i actually move too early goodbye oh they have res though so it didn't matter
I shall take the corner.
There's no way they'll know I'm here.
Bro, I'm trying.
Bro, you have snowflake.
You have as much resources.
You have so many resources.
You literally have resources for days.
Oh my god.
Just a little bit too much.
I just need you to know you have so much resources.
years i i'm trapped okay all right that's fine oh hello man oh my you know what guys guys it's good that i ulted because it dilated the enemy luna ult so if they were like oh why did you of that um i'd be like i got the luna uh that's my excuse true
you had snowflake you had everything all the resources in a row you cannot be complaining about that you literally had everything bro okay i looked away you have snowflake you have No, you're getting passive healing from me healing the tank.
Oh my god.
Okay, I was gonna say, if I reflect...
Okay, I looked away for one second.
There is like 20 people around us, so...
Um, there is, like, I don't know, a Namor behind me.
I will say I am doing a lot of healing.
I just can't kill everything.
I just...
Unfortunately...
Unfortunately, like, I can't kill everything.
There happens to be a bit too many people that need healing.
Just a little bit unfortunate.
Alright.
Let's just hope that we can hide from the...
Oh.
There you go.
I...
I don't even know.
I... I don't even know how he died.
I'd be very honest with you.
I don't even know how that happened.
Like, it's actually crazy how you died there.
Like, our DPS must have, like, the worst positioning possible.
Like, I don't know.
Like, I am, I need to know.
What is the positioning of our DPS?
Oh god, oh, I looked up the wrong way
Jesus Christ
I am trying my best
Please Oh my god, please We should win this technically
Oh my god, I did that push up that century.
I, no, we, I'm going to say it.
We don't deserve to win this.
Our team is so much more worse.
I think our team is, uh, it's not as good.
We do not.
We did not deserve.
This is, this is, this is not, I do not believe this is a healer issue.
I, I, bro, there is no way, there is no way they're complaining about healing.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We don't know that, you know, you do not deserve to spam that.
this bad.
How the fuck would the healer be positioned there?
Like, you all, like, would you want me to be in the front line?
Like, there's no way you think I would be there.
There's no way why would you think I'd play there?
Why would you think I'd play there?
There's no way I get blamed for that.
this is real firepower oh he matched it guys he matched it
no no no no
They are not gaslighting me to think I played wrong I I refuse to be gaslit and thinking I fucked up there
No, no rocket has to look rocket has to look I have to look at this
Rocket has to look at you.
Not me.
It is gaslight.
We all saw his...
We all saw their positioning.
There is no way I...
They are begging for heals there.
I know what I saw.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
There you go.
No, not just the Hella.
That's not just the Hella.
It's the Hella and the neighbor.
It's...
It was both of them.
And I was like, there is no way you think I should be there.
We all saw the positioning there.
Why the fuck would I be there?
The unusual comforts.
Round two.
Even when you can't see me, I'll still make you believe me.
Oh god, they won me so bad.
like a jealous x right now it's like the joker when he calls when he calls batman like 70 times
i already have 30k healing i already have 30k healing from all of that four three two one
yeah Okay, I was gonna say there is no way you're already low because I I have to deal with this I hope the raccoon is healing them because I'm focusing on tanks right now
Okay, all right.
I got tanks you get you get the squishies Be fair like Invis is perfect for tank healing
Yeah They use that All right, I hope he's healing you because I have to deal with my two tanks
Okay Here you get this you get this you get this you get this Oh, no, oh no Oh, thank god, okay what's the fuck
okay okay get out of here
oh my god okay i got him
oh eddie there's no way i'm fucking healing front line you have to be asking our rocket for heals i'm i'm the tank healer here Invis is for tanks.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Okay, if we
go here, we fight here.
All right, to be fair, I thought our rocket get what all after me.
Yeah, you got a damage boosted.
Yeah, I was not living that.
That was a lot of damage.
Like, I am doing so much healing.
And I feel like if I was on any other support, I would not be able to heal everybody.
Because thank God they're all like walk, they're all like in the same line too.
How?
There is no way.
You're getting that.
That's all you're getting.
That's...
You're getting that.
Oh my god.
Alright.
it's fine what we did yeah I was like I for one guy the thing is I can't babysit him because both my tanks are up front so I have to like walk up to them
alright alright They don't know where I am.
Ha ha ha ha!
Jesus Christ.
There's so much damage, right?
Alright.
That's fine.
We live to tell...
We live to tell another story.
Oh!
Okay.
I already have almost 50k healing.
I think if we go over time, it'd be 60.
I actually almost have 50k healings.
Thank God he's not talking to me.
Do reload, please.
Please, I can't!
I...
Okay.
All right.
I didn't know that majority of them were dead.
I...
Oh, that's unlucky.
Oh, I should have saved that.
I got scared.
I didn't want to peek it, so I thought there were like 20 people still alive.
I legitimately thought there were 20 people still alive over there.
I got too scared to peek it.
Oh, what the fuck?
There's no way I died because of you.
I refuse to...
Oh my god.
Okay, we're okay, we're okay, we're okay.
I was like, I refuse to die for you.
I'm in a hallway now.
And he took the health back too.
And he fucking took the health back.
I was like, I will not die for this man.
I get 19 for that, too.
That's the fucking worst part.
I got 19 for the fucking insane play I had to do.
What is it?
Huh?
Oh my god.
What the fucking gameplay I have to do after that?
So yeah, the worst part is I bet they got like plus 30 and I just get 19 points.
You know it too.
You know I got, I got plus 90, like they got plus 30.
does someone click the no no no no part for me i want to see oh
my god
oh all right guys sadly i have to call it guys i have to call it guys because i think i got another noise complaint which is understandable because that game i was mad so we have to call it here yeah they're knocking on the door yeah
unlucky yeah yeah they're hard knocking on the door right now so i have to i have to call it here
um i don't know i didn't open the door yet but that's barking because of it but i got caught it here everyone it was fun though it was fun um i'll be soundproofing my room later today uh not like yesterday sorry on sunday slash monday so that's why i won't be streaming in the next two days because um um but no i'll be soundproofing this room on sunday and monday uh and then i mean i was gonna have to take that to the vet to the hospital like the vet hospital to get his uh uh prescription stuff anyway um so you can hear the noise complaint so i can stream at my dj hours that sucks though it sucks because like i didn't think i i mean i did get really mad during the last game i didn't why did i get mad i didn't get mad i just got like you for the last game yeah I got very passionate I wasn't mad it was just super passionate it's 11 p.m.
too it's not even that late the thing is the thing is um it's just I'm loud so so like like to them it's like I guess like any noise is a for them um um so it's like you know i got a noise complaint at like 10 32 so i think it's just new neighbors which um i guess i don't know i don't know i don't understand why my old neighbors never said anything i thought i was okay the thing is i i thought like i was like not that like my apartment was like really soundproof in general uh because like um i never got any for an entire year plus of streaming yeah so um um yeah so i thought like i thought like uh every my apartment was super soundproof just because like i didn't get any and i had neighbors i saw people coming out of the doors and everything um i saw people coming out of there so i know like there were people living there and they never like confronted me before or like you know um like went up to me and be like hey you're too loud you know I never had that before uh so I didn't
realize I didn't realize that I was that loud like I didn't realize that like people could hear me I didn't realize people could hear me so like uh so like I was just surprised um and uh but yeah i don't want to push it too much because like um i um i am getting soundproofing done on sunday and monday so by then by then it would be fine by then i can be like by then like um no more complaints and i can be as loud as i want um but yeah i hope you guys enjoyed today's stream sorry it's a little short like i said i don't want to push my luck too much um i don't want to push my luck too much today so uh i hope you guys all have fun watching um as always everybody stay hydrated posture get up and move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed cause you deserve it you're right today is my rest day so i did stream quite a lot for a rest day anyway but i did got you guys did cheer me up a lot you guys did cheer me up a lot and it made me a lot happier i did like i
said i did have like a really rough day today um so thank you guys guys thank you again guys for coming um if you guys want to support me via enemies please please nominate me for best marvel rival streamer it'll mean a lot um i would love if you guys could nominate me for best marvel rival streamer um if you guys uh if you guys want to support me other means please check out my merch store um and if you guys want to check me on uh one whenever i stream on twitch please feel free to follow me on twitter because that's usually where I advertise my Twitch streams.
Anyways, I'm sorry I had to cut it short.
I'm sorry, everyone.
I would stream another hour or so if I could.
If I didn't get knocking on my door and everything, I would have streamed a little bit longer.
But I don't want to push my luck.
I know, yeah, there's still outside the door.
So I got to go answer the door and then I just get...
confronted i'm a bit nervous about that because i never had that happen before i never had like noise complaints before and even in university when i got confronted for playing overwatch uh was it overwatch sorry it was i don't remember but yeah it was like yeah i think it was like overwatch too loud oh my gosh i'm trying to remember what what game it was it was it was like it was yeah i think it was overwatch too loud like i had uh i had like someone knocking on my door really loudly and then i just was just quiet i didn't say anything i didn't even open the door because i didn't want to i didn't want to get i didn't want to like get confronted and i just just started whispering and was like oh no yeah i even like pretend like you know i was in the room but i just didn't open my door so i'm always so scared of confrontation like so anyway guys i guess i'll have to confront i guess i have to open the door anyway guys there's always everybody say hi you're ready to pause check out i'm
around to get that blood floor uh and you say over me head to bed because you deserve it uh i won't be rating anyone tonight i'm just gonna head off uh so bye bye everyone uh tomorrow i'll be streaming the Street Fighter tournament.
Maybe after tournament I'll do more.
I'll do another rival stream.
I'll do one more.
I don't know.
Depends.
Maybe not.
Maybe I'll just be tired.
No promises.
No, I won't be streaming another rival stream tomorrow.
I'm gonna stick with it.
I don't want to like force myself to because I was like, oh, I said I was going to.
But no, just Street Fighter.
Just Street Fighter tournament tomorrow on YouTube.
I'll make the waiting room later.
Anyway, bye guys.
Bye.
No rating tonight.
Just disperse.
Go wherever you want to go.
Bye bye everyone.
Bye.